attorney Lisa bloom is now under fire
after reportedly offering money to women
willing to accuse the president of prior
harassment at the very least bloom
engaged in a perverse kind of financial
incentive to attract accusers truth
being a perhaps secondary consideration
now bloom is going on the attack
smearing the reporter who broke the
story John Solomon of the hill calling
him a far-right journalist in reality
John has broken many important stories
this year he joins us now with his side
of the story
John you far-right journalist the AP
stories about rape in the Congo all
those years ago I mean you want to words
and so forth but by the way I had I in
law school I had a license plate on my
Honda Civic there was a far-right so
does that my part you clearly are
everyone thought it was very funny
so she's on the attack saying that
you're distorting what really happened
it's not fair
what's your reaction you know I learned
a long time ago I've been an
investigative reporter 30 years if you
can't attack the facts you try to do in
that hominem attack on the reporter the
facts are unassailable and it is true
that though she says she wrote
represented women pro bono she had a
nice way of collecting a 33% Commission
by selling their stories to the tabloids
it's unassailable that she ranged for
donors possibly related to the election
to pay these women money and and I think
the women at least one of the women
described a lot of pressure she felt as
the election day got nearer for her to
try to come out and make these
allegations against Trump those are
things that are not in dispute this is
what Lisa bloom told joy read over the
weekend let's watch donors reached out
to us and said my god what can we do to
help her or other women come forward
they're in fear you know we have this
very unequal playing field here and we
discussed arranging for security and
relocation services for any women who
wanted it I want to be very clear
neither Hilary Clinton
nor anyone from her campaign was
associated with any of those offers for
relocation and security John no one from
the campaign Hillary didn't know
anything about
what little factoid should she leave out
in that yeah one of them and she will
not answer whether she talked to the
Clinton super PACs which is where the
real big money is in the election right
the candidates are capped at $2,400
super PACs can take a lot of money she
will not answer the question I've asked
it a hundred times can't get an answer
out of her she also didn't talk about
that little mortgage payment for that
house in Queens
yeah one of the women got offered
$750,000 you could buy the Secret
Service detail for that you don't need
that much protection there was other
things going on the woman said one of
them one of their mortgage get paid the
other woman said I want my college
tuition for my kids paid it was a lot
more than security I want to read an
email a story that you broke tonight on
the hill from Jill hearth the New York
makeup artist who accused President
Trump in in a suit she ultimately
dropped in 1997 alleging some type of
misconduct this is what she wrote she
wrote to Trump's assistant Rona Graff I
also want to put it out there that I
would be willing to say at a rally or
somewhere or somewhere how Trump help me
with my self-confidence and all positive
things about he is with women to counter
any potential negativity that may come
out at some point in the campaign now
this is from a woman who opposed suppose
I was going to come out and it came out
and said oh he mistreated me but between
or to grope me or something like that
that she in between her two accusations
there's a much greater context of this
email she wanted a job with the Trump
campaign she asked to be his campaign
make up art someone gropes you you
actually filed a suit that you
ultimately dropped but you obviously
can't like him alleged allegedly did
this then she wants to work in the
campaign I don't know makeup artist more
than that she wanted him to be the
pitchman for her new cosmetic for
anything else no that's it those are the
two things about it man
what was it man scarify what was Donald
Trump gonna have like mascara on what
was he possibly gonna put on there was a
whole male beauty product well some sort
of pitchman work yeah absolutely
yeah but she she came out and said
tonight that oh it I I had gotten over
you prior but she was mad that Donald
Trump said it didn't happen that's right
it's our social
ridiculous if you follow her story she
was angry at him they're not angry at
him do my makeup line I don't like you
yeah working a business deal and they
got angry at him again when he denied
the allegations Lisa bloom said that
none of this changes the fact that she
did not tell women to make up stories
that's right and that you you wrote that
in your original piece
none of the women said they were asked
to say you know there was one episode
that is kind of interesting one woman
was asked to take all of her pro Trump
comments down from Facebook so that her
story would be more believable so that
did happen oh okay but they see what
they weren't told you say this and I'll
give you expert not at all
well it's so good to talk to a far-right
journalist tonight and all of all of
your credentials a weird feeling sound
to me all right
John it's always great to see you thanks
I appreciate it